rules succeed in business and life from
Titans billionaires and leaders who
change the world yeah I love it
what's the belief nation it's an
exciting day because it's time to open
up the samples for my new book so I
decided on my vacation that I wanted to
launch my new book December 6 it was the
same day that I launched my year one
word book last year and I thought it's
number six this year we're gonna launch
and it's a top ten rules of success team
I want to say hi there's team oh yeah
there's team oh look at that keep here
you know what let me take the frisbee
and hold it up here so the team looks at
the camera see look at that look at that
look at that oh my goodness the book is
the top ten most a success that took
fifty of the most popular videos on my
channel condense everything down into
one book it's two rules per page the
idea hopefully that I have in my head is
how I saw it playing out is don't just
read the whole book all the way through
but read one page at a time one page per
day is an easy commitment right you're
reading one page that's all you have to
do for the day read one page you get two
valuable lessons someone who's had tons
of success and then you apply that think
about how can I apply this thing this
new lesson one of these two to my life
for my business today and so that's the
plan and so what I have here are the
samples one of the things I did last
time
last year that was really helpful what
what oh yeah and I printed my own that
was that was that was a disaster
that was a disaster hold on boys anyway
one of the things that did last year was
I gave my book as a sample to 30
different people half for entrepreneurs
half an entrepreneur's and I got their
feedback and it was really great
feedback it ended up cutting my book in
half and I made a number of changes
based off of the feedback I got from the
people so December 6 is approaching
quickly and I need to get my samples in
so that I can give it to another batch
of 30 people here in Toronto and get
their feedback to see what I can do to
improve it wrap it all together put it
put it into a nice finished product for
you guys and have it ready to ship this
number six I'm excited the bosses people
team off don't like my boxes now I'm
self-publishing this one I'm testing the
difference and Amazon has a create space
program that you can sell publish and
order some samples but the only let you
order five samples what's up with that
Amazon I don't I don't get why and
wasn't own lets you order five samples
of your book as a proof before it goes
live so these are the ones that I have
from Amazon and then I have to go to a
printing house to get it printed just on
paper what are you doing what are you
doing huh what are you doing mister huh
huh so I printed off thirty copies just
on on regular paper that people are
going to review and then these are the
official ones that came from Amazon that
I went to
so if chemo will let me if Timo will let
me we're gonna open it up I mean that
you will the thirty copy than you learn
oh yeah I'm just in case that in case we
have extra it's good to have it's good
to have extra just good to have
batteries in case okay let's let's save
this one I want to do that well let this
one go Nina go here to open it there it
is use your razor sharp Wolverine claws
this is very exciting
the unboxing event don't stop me don't
stop me with your Nina's gonna wanna
have the first one as usual so I'm down
the oh you don't want this you only want
the Amazon copy
Wow
did you happen to printed this size he
so this is a great that's it on the
carpet I see the anchor you see the rage
I wasn't gonna just I got this printed
and this listen this is great service
here's the lettuce a great story around
this this guy Nina found online okay
that's not the that's not the story okay
we found this online Nina found this
online and I contacted him and I have a
Word document that I gave him and
normally it were dog was eight and a
half by eleven and as he saw the
document he gave me a price and as he
opened it up he then said listen I see
that you're printing at a smaller page
like the page size is different it'll be
cheaper if we print at the size that you
gave us instead of printing it in a half
by eleven I'm like yeah maybe let's do
that I love that what's the Saint
Patrick I love that Patrick from the
printing house I love that and so but
then what happened then what happened I
gave him a whole bunch of business I'm
giving him stickers from trenwith and
salsa we're gonna do a door rap at TBS
absolute okay okay I'm gonna wrap the
door giving him that I gave him I'm
getting some business cards we would do
flat like I'm giving it a whole bunch of
business because I love this guy yeah he
was really like so just that little
extra customer service like he's losing
a little bit of money because he's
printing that this sizes that everything
to have my eleven but he's gaining a
whole lot of business and so I'm gonna
be good testimony so this will be the
actual size that's pretty good I think
it's the same size as the other as the
your one workbook so so every so here's
an example let me let me show you guys
an example let's flip open so it starts
off with oh let me do the Steve Jobs
worth I don't have one graphic graphic
here looks amazing look at this okay so
I have a guy who's designing graphics we
only did one he's working on the other
so it's gonna start off you see Steve
Jobs and then there's a quote from Steve
Jobs and I'm picking a famous quote and
here so that's one page right there's
one rule first rule is don't live a
limited life second rules have passion
right and like the Steve Jobs thoughts
on that that's it
read this page in one day and then do
something about this think about it
here's some wisdom from Steve Jobs to
what the best thing he's ever said and
start taking some action on it
so that's the idea and so then let me
show you what happens so we've got that
Steve Jobs we've got the rules so that
will be five pages of rules three four
five six this is awesome seven eight
nine ten we beat when I say what my
favorite rule is to just like it doing
the videos my favorite rule so you guys
can check that out and then I have a
page I'm uncertain about this so I'd
love to know what you guys think and for
that I'm gonna get this from the
feedback for my test audience too I've
got the summary so the top ten rules
like what they are space for you to fill
out what you learned from it what you
want to apply anything kind of lessons
from it and then did you know fact
something different something unique
hopefully something maybe you haven't
learned about that entrepreneur or maybe
something you do know so Steve Jobs here
did you know Steve Jobs sold his
Volkswagen microbus to raise the funds
to start Apple so what each person is a
little kind of mini fact at the bottom
that you may or may not know and then
that's it you move on next is Tony
Robbins and it's gonna go through at the
start of this book this is this is
awesome
so the first page is around bonuses so
it says like do you want to you can we
put it up here do you want free bonuses
and one of the things that I really
regret from the first book you're one
worth what I regret is we didn't get the
email addresses for a lot of people and
so the people who bought the book at
Barnes & Noble or Amazon or bookstores
who didn't come from my email list they
didn't get the bonuses because if you
email your receipt or a picture the book
as a into the email address you get
bonuses there's a lot of cool bonuses
and just follow-up in bonus videos and
all sorts of awesome content that's free
if you bought the book I just don't know
who bought the book and so I can't send
them all the free stuff and so the first
page is do you want free bonuses and
then
kind of what you get if you buy one book
two books ten books and the email
address so hopefully people who buy it
even if sign Amazon and don't come for
my list will be able to get it then then
then then then then then here's a list
of the top 50 those are the people and
then I talked about don't read the book
like a book read to pay from one page a
day I thought what could why I wrote
this book you know good stuff and then
here this is what I'm excited about to
the all-time top 10 rules and so what I
do is I took all those 50 people so
that's 50 times 10 500 rules that are in
this book
from the most successful people in the
world and that condense them their most
important rules so ones that come up the
most common from across all these
different people so what are the most
common top ten goals and my quick take
on it is next we have a cheat sheet for
success that we're gonna turn into a PDF
that if you want you can you can print
it off like I want a poster size thing
you can put on your wall if you want to
remember the top 10 things so I think
this is really exciting the top 10 of
the top 500 and then we get into the top
hop on the rules and you have Steve Jobs
so you seen that and all the way through
and then so exciting how do we end it
how do we end it and then just some
things on what you can do after like
make sure you send in their email but to
get the bonuses you know in some final
words for me about Evan and then that's
it and so I took out I was wondering do
I need to add anything else of the book
I was looking at other books do we need
a forwards and introduction table of
contents index all this stuff that as I
looked at other books like I never read
that stuff so I don't want it in my book
so there's no long introduction there's
no long preface or preface preface
forget man I'm blanking there's no long
in chosen to anything it's just right
into the awesome content so this is it
I'm so pumped
last time I printed this on Alex's house
and it took way more work than I thought
and then I think it finally run out of
paperbacks out of ink and they're just
wait bigger I believe bigger projects I
thought and so this look at all this
this is
okay Wow so now we gotta I gotta find my
test audience why I wrote the peoples
already have my test on its but I got it
I gotta give it to them I'm so excited
doesn't smell like anything I know but
it makes me a little sad that it has no
smell
well my own top ten is really similar to
the top ten of I don't know like my top
ten is similar to leave all-time top ten
because I also picked the ones that like
resonate the most - right but my top ten
like whiter Evans top ten rules is the
most requested top ten rules on the
channel okay so I got out we can take
pictures and send this to people maybe
this weekend we're gonna we're gonna set
it up boom alright friends you guys
check out Nina's healthy dinner we got
basa fish
oh I spill baby girl oh my god what are
you doing should we clean that up
yes okay we have basa fish with spinach
tomatoes or you put seeds on yours
that's nice beets no radish anyway okay
okay we'll clean up after we will cut it
up after my hands smell like vinegar oh
I can't touch the new stuff let's wipe
it on Teemo Teemo white vinegar alright
we're gonna do clean isn't that amazing
huh JB smells like vinegar it's your
fault that's right look at that this has
a smell you see oh you can't see right
yeah okay look at that guy this is what
you're gonna get
now this cover is a temporary cover I'm
not a huge fan of this cover it's
okay like it's a great place holder but
I'd love I if you guys have ideas for
what to put on my cover I never liked my
year one word cover and we did up not
time to make it and and I want this one
to be good so this is the this is the
placeholder cover until you guys come up
with something so please if you have
ideas if you are if you are a design
genius and you want to do a cover let me
know I'd love I'd love to see what you
can come up with get some credit and
promotion everything else looks the same
like Steve Jobs came out really well
look at that I guess it's just it's not
spiraled it's not spiraled
look at this this is amazing we're
holding it in our hands huh let me get
the other book I want to compare the
size so this is your one word and this
is this is the new one yeah it's
basically the same size you can't do
hardcover creep space as far as I know
maybe you guys know better as far as I
know you cannot do hardcover with Amazon
CreateSpace so oh man this is so
exciting have I said that enough times
oh there's nothing on the back we
definitely need to put what should be on
the back guys what should go in the back
let me know it's so placeholder it
bothers me that I don't have a full
cover ready to go but we needed
something they wouldn't let you ship
without a cover so the one I made was
really really really bad and so GRI is
on my team made this which is way better
than what I did and really liked what he
did with them like look at the look at
the kind of at the top 10 it's like some
kind of effect on it so it's not just a
flat color a gradient with some patterns
in there
rulz succeed in business and life from
titans billionaires and leaders who
change the world yeah I love it so we
have five of these and we have 30 of
those so what what else we want to tell
them I hope you're excited what do we
need feedback card we need feedback on
cover yes artists
let's see some design some ideas the
back as well that's super important the
face is working the faces I love my I
love my guys the faces look at that
that's gonna be that's great look at
that Steve Jobs let's zoom in on that
look at that look at how great that is
we're gonna have that on each one for
each person it's so much better luck
compared to compared to just that right
Tony Robbins Tony deserves his own
awesome picture that's coming I'm really
happy with that artwork if you know a
way to get Amazon to do hard covers I
want to know
and also people been asking about
pre-orders can you pre-order how do we
pre-order I believe there's a way to do
pre-orders on Amazon and don't know how
to do it again if you guys have tips
feedback advice let me know I think I
need to have a final version ready which
I don't have yet if you're interested in
in picking it up I'm doing a pre-order
and some kind of special deal let me
know you can email my assistant Sandra
at Evan Carmichael comm and she can keep
a list of everybody and you'll be the
first to know when it comes live and
then the packages like ideas for
packages for people who buy one book two
books ten books that's always super cool
or any special bonuses of people who buy
early is always interesting to learn as
well I think that's it guys it's
spur-of-the-moment and exciting but it's
gonna be up well better cover but this
is gonna be on the video then I'm so
excited this is great okay thank you
guys so much you're watching we believe
in you hope and continue to
believing yourself teen was flying and
whatever your one word is much love guys
thank you so much for the support it
really means a lot and we'll see you
soon